i i read a couple of things that kind of
pissed me off because i felt like it was
harassment
i felt like you whipped your head around
no i mean it was they violated you like
i read an article where marshall faulk
like uh yeah and i remember that and
let me tell you yes the truth is
yes and he got hit for that a little bit
on on social media
but the truth is i kind of have this
understanding you have to realize i'm
for the most part a lot of people know
me as a comedian
so and i've made it you're approachable
well and and not only that i've i've
talked about it within the context of
comedy you know
made it light not with that particular
incident you're talking about was on
deal or no deal
and it became kind of a funny thing
because people were excited there
and they wanted to hug me and like you
know what happened i wasn't
what happened exactly oh he said you
know he goes he's a germaphobe i'm gonna
shake your hand i'm gonna shake her hand
and he was chasing me around the set and
he grabbed my hand and he shook my hand
and the truth is i didn't get triggered
that particular day but people are right
they're going listen
i and it's the people that are suffering
the same thing as me
when they understand it's it's real and
even though i make joke and
make jokes about it like it's you know
what is real and what's not real is he
is he making jokes about being a
germaphobe who doesn't like jokes and is
he
exaggerating it it's kind of funny to
play that
joke on me you know what i mean like
it's chasing murray langston around the
office
to pull the bag over his head but it's
very funny
but it's not funny if you you're
triggered if i would have been triggered
it probably would have ended badly but i
wasn't triggered but i kind of
understand humanity and i understand
people don't know about it we're talking
about this in america
you're right now today and people who
are listening to this podcast
it's a much different world but you know
and and and people are taking mental
health really seriously and mental
health has become
part of our pop culture you know people
are open about
drinking people are opening you know
look britney spears all over the
the news right now and there's much more
of a compassionate
lil to it than there was the first time
that she was in the news
with all with all that so it was a
different time yeah
yeah that is kind of a
what that did for me rather than feeling
anything
uh negative about marshall i just
realized that's the world
the world doesn't understand the world
if i'm not bleeding and i'm not
unconscious
then they don't understand suffering and
even on this podcast i don't know if
people watch this zoom call
but i you know i'm sitting i'm sitting
in a house i'm smiling
i have a an amazing career i feel like
one of the luckiest people in the world
and uh
what kind of [ __ ] suffering is that